a atuação apagada na realidade a bola na
área
efe se você quer ser milionário em
uma mina na outra final na china
e aí o clima da onu lunar o seu nome
disse gleide bispo ao ross
[Silence]
nem nós outra para o de professor
rio ae
uai a rádio onu
ele deve ir a campo com pipo cantor bem
de cada rua long e não sendo de cada
andré cunha só vá andou a onu tem fio
da holanda foi pior só o fiz na bola e
só quem vão poder não sei diz o fed ou
de meio e deixou as mãos numa estudo diz
morbey lá lhes 10 da lei disse em deixem
de grey ipp bom som não olha aí o cmse
andem o alfa considera
olha foi i é torrent andré resistir e
brancos primo falou exemplo morreu
[Silence]
francis tam se rasgou
ele te digo olha ali nash
o chef andré t nice bahia anda o lula
ainda tem de resolver no dia de hoje
queixa na lei
ae o dó lá e sei tudo de rua logo a 10
ainda iphone ou é viva da lei
o enda campo luís deles na hora dele que
for
a moça vai fechar uma rua de díos se é
óleo é vez da e
a bn site celebrity natura on it de
ordem hoje foi o anúncio dentro de
conflito da ponte nas apoio de países
nou demon o dodô toalha anda tenho fundo
do ciclo
hoje é a vez de a gente então lá de guy
the good the da hora de eu sou eu agora
e se é que a idéia é fornecer aiai da
free way to do office da já não dei
inútil nosso panorama 6 mo
andei o vavá vai conselho da nossa
intenção do bc há ano
o filme xuxa que ela faz e chutou
nenhuma ele lhe fez a pole day que nós
lhes diz ansioso